the cost of living crisis has been
staring us in the face for six months
now and it's a real problem for people
struggling with their bills um and the
cabinet meeting this morning isn't going
to change any of that um you know we've
got a government that has done very
little in relation to energy bills it's
made a bad situation worth by choosing
to put taxes up this month this week
people will see they pay packet with
less in it so we need an emergency
budget to grip this situation and at the
very least in that budget i want to see
a windfall tax on oil and gas companies
in the north sea made more money than
they were expected more profit and use
that directly to pay up to 600 pounds
off the bills of those most in need and
i also want to see the reversal of this
increase in tax the wrong tax at the
wrong time so an emergency budget not a
cabinet meeting
so would you have to raise other taxes
to fund support for people because even
600 pounds won't cover the increase in
people's bills would it well an
emergency budget which included a
windfall tax on oil and gas companies
would
allow up to 600 pounds off the bills of
so many people
who are in need but also we need to get
rid of the tax rise because people will
be opening their pay packet this week
and and seeing that not only are their
bills going up but their income has gone
down because the government has chosen
to tax them at the moment so at the very
least we need those two measures i've
been talking here in stevenage to
businesses
and we need measures to support
businesses as well i'd like to see
business
rate relief for businesses i'd also like
to see more support for businesses that
are energy
efficient and beyond that i also
desperately want the government to claw
back the 11.8 billion pounds that they
lost in fraud or bad contracts during uh
the pandemic so the argument the
government's trying to put forth there's
nothing we can do is absolute nonsense
for many people here of course the cost
of living crisis will be their number
one issue you spent a lot last week
talking about partygate that fine that
the prime minister received have the
shadow cabinet told you to start talking
more about the cost of living rather
than going on about the party gate when
we started the local election campaign
we had a laser-like focus on the cost of
living and we've maintained that
throughout the campaign and that's why
this week we're calling for that
emergency budget because
the government has done so little it's
not risen to the to the challenge that
so many people are facing and it's made
a bad situation worse and the choice not
to go after the fraud money the choice
to impose tax is the government's choice
so i'm very happy to talk about that all
day long um the problem with partygate
is that you know the government itself
is distracted it was the prime minister
who had to come to parliament to make a
statement because it received a fine
from the metropolitan police so
whilst they're embroiled in an argument
within their own party so many people
are struggling with their bills are you
happy the police are dealing with it
appropriately because the fines are just
dripping out very very slowly aren't
they
i think that just should be maximum
transparency um here we need to know
what's going on um and i'd like that to
continue as the principle country
started on the local elections what
would success look like for labour well
we've got a fantastic team of candidates
across the country
um we're putting for a very strong
argument
i know that we've got to earn every vote
i'm not taking anything for granted but
all of our teams
are picking up when they talk to people
on their doorsteps that people are
really fed up with the government that
is spending his whole time trying to
defend the indefensible in relation to
partygate and not enough of its time
focused on what's really concerning them
which is their energy bills and the fact
that this month they're getting even
more tax than they got before because
the government has chosen to impose more
tax on them in the middle of a cost of
living crisis so we've got a positive
case um we're making that case to the
electorate and this is a chance really
for people who are fed up with the
government to send a message to them and
do you appreciate that you would need to
make significant gains for it to be
deemed a success for labour well look we
do need to
make gains we need to hold what seats
we've got we need to increase our vote
share particularly after 2019 but we've
got a fantastic set of candidates for
making a very positive case can i just
ask a couple more one on ed balls are
you disappointed that he won't be
standing in wakefield as and when that
by-election comes well that's a matter
for ed balls
we the disgrace tory mp in wakefield
said he would resign and he still hasn't
actually resigned so um you know
wakefield deserves better than that um
he should get on with it so we can have
a by-election and when we have a
by-election we'll have an excellent
local candidate for labour and just on
jeremy corbyn any child are taught that
he could be a labour mp again at the
next general election i've made my
position very clear in relation to
jeremy corbyn and there's obviously a
process um in place
and so i don't think there's much more i
can say about that